investi par la république en marche
nadia et est élu député dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines en jouant
2017 ses collègues députés dont le
département salue sa nomination comme
ministre délégué à la ville très très
heureuse pour nadia et que je connais
bien puisque nous avions fait notre
campagne des législatives
ensemble donc également j'ai été très
très fier de voir qu'une personne jeunes
motivés dynamiques travailleuses et bien
aujourd'hui et est nommé ministre
délégué à la vie une très très bonne
nouvelle d'avoir une parlementaire
une femme de trappes qui devient
ministre délégué ça c'est évidemment une
très grande fierté pour les yvelines et
puis pour pour son parcours je trouve
que que c'est amplement mérité
la deuxième raison c'est que on a enfin
séparé à la fois le logement et la
politique de la ville puisque du temps
de gildan normandie il y avait cette
grande difficulté ou là le dossier
logement et le dossier politique de la
ville était sous sa responsabilité
parmi les élus de la 11e circonscription
celle de nadia et la maire de saint cyr
l'école espère que la nouvelle ministre
sera plus à l'écouté des acteurs de
terrain et des problématiques
rencontrées
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui lui
tenait à coeur on a eu à plusieurs
reprises l'occasion d'échanger sur leurs
les politiques de la ville sur les
difficultés qu'on pouvait rencontrer je
lui souhaite bonne chance et je lui
demande de ne pas oublier pâtir qui
n'est pas le plus politique de la ville
n'est dont elle connaît les difficultés
à trappes
l'ancien maire guy malandain a travaillé
avec nadia et notamment sur les
questions de politique de la ville et de
rénovation urbaine
il se souvient de ses collaborations
avec la ministre natif de trappes
elle avait piloté si je m'en souviens
bien une équipe de députés qui faisait
un rapport sur la politique de la ville
au moment où monsieur borloo préparer
son
son document c'est bien que ce soit dur
biblis parce que c est là elle sait de
quoi elle parle
et ce sont aussi des éléments qui
étaient là vécu et donc on n'est pas
dans le superficiel ou des théories au
sein de l'assemblée nadia et avait
notamment travaillé sur les questions de
politique de la ville
en mars elle avait d'ailleurs organisé à
ce titre une table ronde sur l'image des
quartiers populaires pas assez pour
ralliera bemer de sa circonscription
plutôt critique à sa nomination
j'invite la majorité présidentielle en
général le gouvernement le président de
la république le premier ministre à ne
pas utiliser la politique de la ville
comme un gadget à nommer des
personnalités qui en sera issu et se
contenter du symbole nous n'avons plus
besoin de symboles
nous avons besoin de mesures concrètes
n'ajjer nous ne l'avons pas beaucoup vu
sur le terrain soyons honnête elle était
peut-être au travail à l'assemblée
faudrait aller vérifier mais j'espère
que comme ministre elle sera davantage
sur le terrain auprès des habitants de
banlieue qu'elle ne l'a été comme député
de notre ville une nomination que ne
comprend pas également jean michel
fourgous maire d'elancourt et président
de saint quentin en yvelines
dans des propos rapportés par le
parisien c'est une surprise le président
est un homme de théâtre qui choisit les
figures être élu à trappes suffit
manifestement être en vue pour ce poste
encore une fois l'image prime sur la
compétence je n'ai rien contre elle mais
elle manque encore d'une vraie
implantation locale
je lui souhaite juste bonne chance
d'autres réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment celle de karl olive
maire de poissy
un temps pressenti dans le remaniement
du gouvernement un message de
félicitations sur twitter à présent
reste à savoir qui remplacera à nadia et
à l'assemblée madame nadia et